obviously the big story this week is the
prisoner swap we got back sergeant Bowe
Bergdahl from Afghanistan in exchange
for five Taliban prisoners from
Guantanamo Bay there is all kinds of
stuff going on that by the time we post
this will probably change there's some
questions to whether six soldiers
actually died while looking for him he
may have been a deserter and had not
been captured actually all kinds of
stuff but I wanted to talk about this
Jeffrey Toobin on CNN he is their legal
analyst I often don't agree with him on
a lot of stuff usually about the NSA but
he's saying that President Obama
actually broke the law by not going to
Congress before authorizing the prisoner
release let's take a look you've looked
at the law you've looked at the signing
statement you've gone through it did the
president break the law by engaging in
this deal oh I think he clearly wrote
the law the law says 30 days notice he
didn't gave 30 days notice now it is
true that he issued a signing statement
but signing statements are not lost
signing statements are the president's
opinion about what the law should mean
now it may be that the law is
unconstitutional a violation of his pad
powers from an der of chief but no court
has held that the law is on the books
and he didn't follow it ok so as far as
i know we still have something called
the constitution in this country even if
we don't pay that much attention to it
so yes he had this signing statement but
that doesn't supersede the law so that's
what I want to talk about here does
anyone care about the law line to say
like are we still surprised that Obama
broke the law I mean what about ordering
a drone strike on an American citizen
without due process in secret what about
the unprecedented warn whistleblowers
what about spying on the American people
with the NSA are counting dead
military-aged males killed by drone
strikes as combatants or signing into
law the enshrining of the executive
power to indefinitely detain terror
suspects without trial really we're
surprised yeah so well done came you
took care of for my bullet point there
sorry yeah no that was perfect that was
perfect that was my point that we've
done so much of this doesn't excuse it I
mean no sure we're not surprised but I
don't think it excuses it I mean I think
in this particular case does really
matter that Congress gotta prove
probably not really because they would
probably agree with it anyway so in this
particular case I don't really think it
matters i think the bigger issue is that
this keeps happening and it's sad that
we're not surprised about it yeah so
President Obama did issue a statement
about this we have consulted with
Congress for quite some time about the
possibility that we might need to
execute a prisoner exchange in order to
recover sergeant Bergdahl we saw an
opportunity we were concerned about
sergeant Bergdahl's health we had the
cooperation of Qatar ease to execute an
exchange and we seize that opportunity
and the process was truncated because we
wanted to make sure that we did not miss
that window now what they are also
saying is that Bergdahl had some health
issues now he's being checked right now
but it's no one knows where he is
exactly so we haven't been able to
verify that that there was some sort of
health issue that made this you know
that they needed to have this happen
immediately so even that statement
though like I get it like he's like we
are we wanted to make this happen want
to make a quick it's sensitive but again
that doesn't supersede the law so should
anyone should we do anything about this
because I think this is the type of
thing that the media is just going to
drop and it's like I he broke the law
again Zippity doo-dah I think because it
made strategic sense we're not that
upset about it right but I think the
major issue is that they keep he keeps
breaking the law this administration the
former administration keeps breaking the
law and a lot of times it doesn't make
sense and we don't get an explanation so
I think though that if we had more trust
in the government then stuff like this
would be more passable I think I'm just
really upset because this is just
another example of how the law is not
followed and how we are not given
information at all and you mentioned so
many things that all those things we all
forgot about so all of those things when
you add up all those things are those
how do you think we're going to look
back at the Obama presidency especially
when it comes to these sort of security
issues and the spying and all that like
he really in my opinion at least has
severely dropped the ball here well yeah
but we're sort of used to him dropping
the ball but in this case I feel like we
know so little about Bergdahl's you know
was he deserter res he's sick how many
people died looking for him where is he
now they're so there's such a lack of
transparency that I think will will
remember for a long time would any of
that change your opinion
this if it turned out that he was really
sick and they knew he had two weeks to
live with that then mitigate you saying
well okay he can he can go ahead and
break as we want him back before he dies
I think again I think in this particular
situation I'm not part AB set about the
strategic yeah um you know move that was
taken and it broke the law because laws
are meant sort of as safeguards they're
meant to like guy that those are made to
be broken yeah they're meant to be
broken because sometimes they don't make
sense um but the issue is that these
laws keep being broken when we don't
have any information or any transparency
as you mentioned as to why it makes
sense to break the law yeah do you think
the mainstream media might be more upset
about this if it was say President Bush
well you'll have to remember that
present their precious President Reagan
did a similac chief are worse created
weapons to Iran yeah and it was a huge
failure and we kind of forgot about that
isn't he the messiah of the Republican
Party now right and also people were
saying well we don't negotiate with
terrorists that's what that's what
everyone on the right on the
Conservatives were all saying right now
except we've done it with the pattern
this was a negotiation this was a
prisoner swap which is different than
negotiating with terrorists it's or it's
sort of a negotiation but it's not
exactly there yeah that's all that's a
whole other topic but so this story is
going to just keep going on and I'm sure
we'll cover more of it next week